alors là pour faire très simple vous
avez un corps au nadir de cours en
algérie sans cesse et un virus à arn qui
va être juste là le corona virus là une
particularité c'est qu'ici il a une
protéine qu'on appelle la protéine
spikes et la protéine c'est d'ailleurs
cette protéine qui va s'accrocher sur la
cellules pulmonaires et vous rendre
malade
ah merde ce qu'on a réussi à faire et ce
qui est incroyable c'est qu'on a réussi
à déterminer le code génétique de
l'intégralité du virus et on a réussi
grâce à la rn justement à partir d'un
brin arn pouvoir créer justement cette
protéine est ce celle à spike c'est la
protéine spike donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
on va prendre cet arn la rn et hyper
fragile et si on le met directement il
va être détruit c'est pour ça qu'on va
l'entourer d'une couche de lipides qu'on
appelle des nanoparticules c'est pas une
puce 5g qu'on vous mais c'est quelque
chose qui permet de la russie pour
justement éviter que le virus de la
reine se dégrade donc qu'est-ce qu'on
dirait quand on vous vaccine on va vous
mettre cela sur un gars comme ça est
dedans on vous met un peu des arn qu'on
va mettre dans votre cellule qui met
juste là on vous injecte là vous avez de
la rnt dans la cellule qui ce qui va se
passer
eh bien on va créer à ce moment là cette
petite protéine est ce qui m'arrive est
naturellement elle va sortir de la
cellule et une fois qu'elle va être
sorti de la cellule qu'est ce qui va se
passer votre système immunitaire va se
dire ouh là là on est en train de tomber
malade
elle va donc créer des anticorps fort
naturellement plein d'anticorps vont
être créés juste là le jour elle
rencontre le virus c'est à dire une fois
que vous allez rencontrer quelqu'un qui
est malade ni que ça mais au lieu de
tomber malade
vous avez ces anticorps qui sont juste
là qui vont venir se fixer là et qui
vont empêcher
finalement vous de tomber bref ça veut
dire du virus dernière chose est la
chose la plus importante on dit souvent
que la rn change le code génétique oui
eh bien figurez-vous que le code
génétique l'adn il est là où ça ici à
l'intérieur dans le noyau la rn ne va
jamais dans l'adn jamais votre matériel
génétique ne sera jamais jamais changé
la seule chose qui va se passer c'est
que votre système immunitaire va créer
lui-même les anticorps et va vous
satiété chasser le teaser qui fait ça
c'est le vaccin à rnc le mac sans faille
sont exactement parce que l'autre
astrazeneca c'est pas pareil c'est un
peu différent on se serre mme c'est ça
la d9 virus c'est-à-dire interviewé sur
lequel on met finalement peu de
particules et vous allez en
centré votre système immunitaire donc en
gros ce qui se passe avec la vaccination
c'est votre
on vous donne un coup de pouce on vous
donne un petit message est celle arn
messager qui vous permet de créer de la
vaccination raison aussi pour laquelle
les personnes âgées ont un peu moins
d'anticorps parce qu'ils ont un système
immunitaire un peu moins performant et
donc en vieillissant ces anticorps et
bien il y en a un peu moins c'est pour
ça que finalement elles sont moins bien
partagée que les jeunes mellal arn
messager ne changera pas votre code
génétique et vous allez juste être
vaccinés protéger de façon naturelle est
alors une personne âgée qui aurait été
vaccinées au yang scène je dis ça comme
ça ouais qualité vingtaine et oriente
scène on peut faire le johnson johnson
ou l'astra zeneca après 55 ans la seule
chose c'est qu'on sait que l'impact est
efficace mais quel que soit le vaccin et
j'ai des patients que hull astrazeneca
en première dose ils vont attraper le
courant à virus parce qu'on sait très
bien qu'une dose n'est pas suffisante et
bien sûr les passions que j'ai eu aucun
n'a fait de formes graves lieu d'aller à
l'hôpital au lieu d'en mourir
eh bien vous aurez un test pcr positif
alors certains ont eu des températures
mais ils n'en sont pas morts et c'est ça
aussi l'enjeu c'est que la vaccination
ça marche ça sauve des vies on se rend
compte qu'en ce moment
l'épidémie est en train de s'écrouler
partout là on vaccine l'épidémie et
décoller et donc c'est une perspective
de retrouver une vie normale
à condition qu'on soit tous vaccinés
pour éviter l'émergence de variantes
florian philippot s'est bêtement elle
s'écroule aussi là où on vaccine
beaucoup moins c'est ça ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure
donc il faut penser que c'est aussi un
type de saisonnalité mais bien sûr c'est
multifactoriel pas comment un même bien
si vous avez de la toussaint vous avez
des pays où je vais ainsi dépôt jours
jours sur le portugal vous avez même
résultat que le revenu même moment où la
même vaccination qu'en france va mieux
c'est bien dans les religions de svt
sciences nat vous avez aimé par le ver
en a fait les schémas pour essayer de
nous convaincre du confinement ça m'a
jamais convaincu
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que les
essais cliniques pour les enfants ça a
commencé en mars
il ya deux mois de recul c'est pas assez
et que sur la rn messages et les essais
cliniques
ils sont deux faces on est dans une
autorisation de mission de la commission
on est sur des essais cliniques qui sont
pas c'est trop tôt florian mais bien sûr
et puis surtout pour les enfants encore
une fois n'y a pas d'intérêt donc on les
utilise un peu comme je lui dis d'une
bouche trou du bush piqûre voilà du
bouche à seringue pour pour pour les
autres et ça c'est inacceptable du point
de vue de l'éthique morale philosophique